First Fourier Series: The Eight Note
[Music]
First Fourier Series, 10x Zoom
First Fourier Series, 100x Zoom
End of First Fourier Series,
Start of Second Fourier Series
Second Fourier Series: The Sigma/Sum Symbol
End of Second Fourier Series,
Start of Third Fourier Series
Third Fourier Series: England, United Kingdom
End of Third Fourier Series,
Start of Fourth Fourier Series
Fourth Fourier Series: Joseph Fourier
End of Fourth Fourier Series,
Start of Fifth Fourier Series
Fifth Fourier Series: Nail and Gear
End of Fifth Fourier Series,
Start of Sixth Fourier Series
Sixth Fourier Series: A Treble Clef
End of Sixth Fourier Series,
Start of Seventh Fourier Series
Seventh Fourier Series: Hilbert's Curve
End of Sixth Fourier Series,
Start of Eighth/Final Fourier Series
Eighth/Final Fourier Series: Seattle, Washington,
United States of America
End of Eighth/Final and Every Fourier Series.